oh hello bagging pierce is the key to
our proxy defense and the defense is
life itself so you put us right in
Episode five when they visited the
pierce is an interesting thing to me is
that the ROI somewhat Outsiders right
Logan Roy and Scottish and Canadian and
his family are one part of the media and
I guess the pieces represent the Peabody
Boston Brahmin longer heritage in the
business
welcome to turn Haven our city on the
hill that clash of cultures appealed to
us and Logan wants in their respect and
he also wants at some level to destroy
him I suppose you've been waiting for
this moment for quite a while happen
greedyguts cherry was fantastic to work
with
she's obviously something of a legend
stage and screen
she had that formidable quality and she
lets the ludicrous nurse of life happen
around her in a good way
cheers everyone and that dinner party
scene the tough thing for Schiff is she
has always been able to see how
expectations and pressures on her
siblings kind of bent them out of shape
and they thought given to to whom you
might hand over the keys why madam that
is very forward and you and Mills one
it's easy to see that happening to other
people but you're the one under the
microscope you can find yourself
behaving in ways you know rationally you
can't smart oh for [ __ ] sake dad just
tell them it's gonna be me
there's lots of times in life out there
when it's easy to be the one watching
and saying that's foolish but when
you're suddenly under the spotlight you
find yourself making unwise decisions my
dad doesn't like to be bashed are there
to be repercussions
you
[Music]
you